una semana de conversaciones cruciales
para moscú con los negociadores esta vez
en bruselas rusia está tratando de
obtener una promesa de eeuu de que la
otan no se expandirá a ucrania pero sus
demandas hasta el momento han sido
ignoradas
hasta ahora no vemos ninguna razón real
para ser optimistas el vicecanciller
jacob dijo que la primera ronda de
conversaciones fue positiva porque fue
abierta sustancial y directa pero
nuestra meta en estas negociaciones no
es conversar es el resultado lo que
importa y no hay nada que decir de eso
por ahora
de hecho para washington y sus aliados
la demanda rusa de mantener a la otan y
sus misiles fuera de ucrania es un
fracaso y para la administración de joe
biden el despliegue de 100.000 soldados
en la frontera con ucrania para mantener
la presión es inaceptable has visto a
medida que continúen estas
conversaciones no habrá éxito a menos
que podamos hacerlo en una atmósfera de
des escalamiento ucraniano debería tener
esa espada de damocles colgada
las autoridades de kiev que no hacen
parte de las negociaciones de esta
semana creen tener todo el respaldo de
eeuu y piden una cumbre internacional
que incluya a francia y alemania- para
resolver la crisis aunque las
conversaciones se siguen muchos
ucranianos temen por una invasión rusa
como estos residentes que ya están
entrenando para luchar no sólo en la
parte oriental del país sino también en
kiev